Auf diesem Kanal
sind wir Freunde der Sonne,
aber wir sind keine
Freunde des Klimawandels!
Irgendwie wissen wir alle, es geht
so nicht weiter, wir müssen was tun,
aber wir wissen auch:
Es ist ned so einfach, ne.
Der Verzicht auf Fleisch
und tierische Produkte
ist gut für die Umwelt,
aber heute fragen wir uns: wie gut?
Mir persönlich würde es z.B.
schwerfallen, vegan zu leben.
Da ist die Frage berechtigt,
ob sich der Aufwand
oder der Verzicht wirklich lohnen.
Können wir mit Veganismus
die Umwelt retten?
Oder sind
andere Maßnahmen effizienter?
Das klären wir jetzt.
* Musik *
Passt auf, das klären wir vorweg:
Ich werde jetzt hier in diesem Video
die ethischen Fragen,
also sollte man Tiere überhaupt
essen, bewusst ausklammern.
Nicht, weil ich diese Frage
nicht wichtig finde,
sondern weil ich möchte, dass wir
uns zumindest in diesem Video
ganz systematisch
nur auf die Umwelt konzentrieren.
Denn das ist schon kompliziert
genug, ihr werdet schon sehen.
Deswegen auch Tee holen gemütlich
machen. Ihr wisst Bescheid: cheers.
Fangen wir an mit den grundlegenden
Grundlagen der Ernährung:
Das Leben dreht sich
um ein Element: Kohlenstoff.
Alles Leben basiert
auf Kohlenstoff-Verbindungen.
In der Luft fliegt Kohlenstoff
in Form von CO2 herum.
Pflanzen können
das CO2 aus der Luft
in komplexere Kohlenstoff-haltige
Moleküle umwandeln:
Zucker, Stärke, Fette.
Wir essen diese Kohlenstoff-haltigen
Verbindungen und wandeln sie um.
Wir nutzen die Energie, die beim
Umwandeln entsteht, zum Leben.
Wir wandeln Sie außerdem in andere
Kohlenstoff-haltige Materie um,
also Gewebe, Muskeln,
Hirn, Haut, Fett.
Und wir atmen CO2 wieder aus.
Das können die Pflanzen
dann wieder aufnehmen,
und so schließt
sich der Kohlenstoff-Kreislauf.
Ich habe Schnittlauch genommen,
um Pflanzen zu demonstrieren,
als ob ihr nicht wüsstet,
was eine Pflanze ist.
Jetzt ist CO2
aber auch ein Treibhausgas.
Und das Problem ist, dass wir das
schon lange nicht mehr nur ausatmen,
sondern durch Industrie und Co.
sehr viel mehr davon freisetzen.
Nur haben wir nicht
entsprechend mehr Pflanzen.
Unser modernes Leben bringt also
den Kohlenstoff-Kreislauf
aus dem Gleichgewicht.
Sagen wir es etwas genauer:
Je mehr Pflanzen wir haben,
desto mehr CO2
ziehen sie aus der Atmosphäre
und desto besser ist es fürs Klima.
Ein Wald bindet mehr CO2
als eine Wiese
und die wiederum mehr als ein Acker.
Deswegen ist die Frage nach
einer klimafreundlichen Ernährung
auch immer verknüpft mit der Frage
der weltweiten Hungerbekämpfung.
Bis 2050 werden wir fast 10 Mrd.
Menschen auf diesem Planeten sein.
Also die Weltbevölkerung wird
irgendwann ein Maximum erreichen
und dann wieder sinken, aber so
viele müssen wir erst mal ernähren.
Wenn die Landwirtschaft
so weitergeht wie bisher,
dann geht das nur
durch zusätzliche Ackerflächen
und die sind hauptsächlich dort,
wo heute Wald ist.
Daher ist es gut fürs Klima, wenn
wir Ackerflächen effizient nutzen.
In der Praxis bringt Effizienz-
maximierte Landwirtschaft
natürlich auch andere Probleme.
Aber für die Grundlagen
ist dieser Zusammenhang wichtig.
Also mit einer
möglichst kleinen Ackerfläche
möglichst
viele Menschen ernähren. So.
Wie nutze ich Ackerflächen
jetzt möglich effizient?
Ich kann auf diesen Flächen Pflanzen
anbauen und die an Tiere verfüttern.
Also Pflanzen in Fleisch umwandeln
oder in Milch.
Doch diese Umwandlung
ist ja nicht verlustfrei.
Weil das Tier einen Großteil
der wertvollen kohlenstoffhaltigen
Grundstoffe verschwendet,
indem es sie in Energie
zum Leben umwandelt
und den Rest einfach ausatmet.
Dreist.
Noch mal, ich mache das
bewusst ganz nüchtern,
dass ich Tiere
hier nur als Energielieferant
oder Nahrungsquelle betrachte,
seht mir das nach.
Ich möchte nur,
dass wir diesen Ernährungspart
logisch nachvollziehen.
Effizienter wäre es, die Pflanzen
vom Acker direkt selbst zu essen,
denn mit jedem Essen geht
durchs Umwandeln Energie verloren.
Anders gesagt: Ich kriege mehr
Kalorien aus einer Ackerfläche,
wenn ich diese Pflanzen
direkt selbst esse,
anstatt, dass ich sie weiter
verfüttere und dann das Tier esse.
Und auch neben
der ineffizienten Flächennutzung
bringen Fleisch und tierische
Produkte noch andere Umweltprobleme.
Ein Problem ist, dass Tiere
rülpsen und furzen, und zwar viel.
Besonders Kühe, Schafe und Ziegen,
denn in so einem
Wiederkäuer-Verdauungssystem
gibt es viele Bakterien,
die viele Gase produzieren,
darunter auch Methan.
Methan ist als Treibhausgas um
ein Vielfaches schlimmer als CO2.
Was machen wir also? Wir holen uns
mit den Pflanzen CO2 aus der Luft
wandeln die um in Tier,
und das Tier stößt dann
ein viel
schlimmeres Treibhausgas aus.
Schlecht für die Klimabilanz.
Und da hört die Geschichte
ja auch noch nicht auf.
Es gibt noch
mehr klimarelevante Emissionen
aus der Fleischwirtschaft.
Das geht von Treibstoff
für die Futtertransporte
bis hin zur Energie
für Verarbeitung und Lagerung.
Und all diese Sachen
muss man berücksichtigen,
wenn man den Umwelt-Impact eines
Nahrungsmittels bewerten möchte.
Und genau das macht man
mit einem Live Cycle Assessment.
Kurz LCA, auch Umweltbilanz genannt.
Wenn man sich die LCAs
verschiedener Lebensmittel ansieht,
fällt sofort auf, das Fleisch
sehr schlecht abschneidet.
Besonders Fleisch von Wiederkäuern
wegen des Methan-Ausstoßes.
Betrachtet man die Klimabilanz,
macht die Tierhaltung weltweit
14,5 % der Menschen-gemachten
Treibhausgas-Emissionen aus.
Das ist ungefähr genauso viel
wie innerhalb derselben Zeit
aus den Auspuff aller Autos
aller Schiffe,
Flugzeuge, aller Transportmittel
kommt. Krass, oder?
Nur, Achtung:
Das bedeutet trotzdem nicht,
dass tierische Lebensmittel alleine
genauso viele Klimagase verursachen
wie der gesamte Transportsektor.
Denn beim Fleisch oder Milch
schauen wir uns LCAs an,
also eine
recht umfassende Betrachtung.
Beim Transport
nur die direkten Emissionen.
Und zusätzliche Emissionen,
die entstehen
durch die Produktion
der Transportmittel
oder durch Ölförderung für Benzin,
das ist da noch gar nicht drin.
Insgesamt verursacht
der Transportsektor
viel mehr Treibhausgase
als die Tiere in unserer Ernährung.
Da ist also auch sehr viel
Spielraum für eine Verbesserung.
Das nur als Einordnung.
Denn 14,5 %
sind natürlich trotzdem enorm viel.
Und jetzt? Um das zu klären,
haben wir uns mit Frank
von Die Frage
zusammengeschlossen.
Die machen gerade
eine ganze Serie zum Klimawandel
und beleuchten ihn jede Woche
von einer anderen Seite.
Frank hat mich auch zu Hause
besucht, aber dazu später mehr.
Wir haben uns konkret gefragt:
Heißt das jetzt nicht
ganz offensichtlich,
dass wir alle Veganer
werden sollten?
Könnten wir dadurch 14,5 %
der Treibhausgase reduzieren?
Damit wäre das Klima
nämlich geschmeidig gerettet.
So einfach ist das nicht, habt ihr
euch wahrscheinlich gedacht.
Nicht nur, weil einfach vegan Leben
nicht so einfach ist,
sondern weil diese Zahl
zwar nicht falsch ist,
aber deutlich vielschichtiger,
als sie scheint.
Und auf diese Schichten
möchte ich jetzt gerne eingehen
in einer Rubrik, die ich nenne:
Here's the thing:
Wir Menschen sind Allesfresser.
Aber Tiere
können Pflanzenteile essen,
die wir gar nicht essen können,
z.B. Mais.
Da essen wir nur die Körner.
Wenn wir den Rest der Pflanze
an Tiere verfüttern
und wir wiederum die Tiere essen,
kriegen wir aus unserer Ackerfläche
mehr Kalorien
und nutzen sie damit effizienter.
Here's the thing:
Man liest immer wieder,
dass weltweit über 70 % der
landwirtschaftlich genutzten Flächen
für die Produktion von Fleisch
und Milch verwendet werden
diese aber nur etwa
18 % der Kalorien liefern,
das klingt ja nach
einer bodenlosen Verschwendung.
Oder
einer bodenvollen Verschwendung.
Aber es gibt Böden, die man
gar nicht anders nutzen kann,
weil sie gar nicht
dazu geeignet sind,
um Nahrungspflanzen
darauf anzubauen.
Gras hingegen ist anspruchslos, das
wächst auch auf schlechteren Böden.
Hier kann man dann
Rinder und Schafe weiden lassen.
2/3 der Flächen, die für Fleisch-und
Milchproduktion verwendet werden,
sind eben solches Weideland, das
für Veganer weitgehend nutzlos ist.
In Sachen
effiziente Flächennutzung gilt hier:
lieber Tiere als gar keine Nutzung.
In Ländern wie Kenia
oder der Mongolei
ist ein großer Teil
der Landwirtschaft
und auch ein großer Teil der
Ernährung der lokalen Bevölkerung
darauf angewiesen,
diese Böden zu beweiden.
Wenn diese Menschen
dort jetzt vegan leben wollten,
müssten sie womöglich Wald abholzen,
um Ackerflächen zu schaffen,
die sie nutzen oder sie wären
auf Importe angewiesen.
Weltweiter Veganismus
wäre also nicht
die allerbeste Lösung fürs Klima.
Jetzt leben wir aber nicht
in der Mongolei oder in Kenia,
sondern in Deutschland,
das nicht für weitläufige
Steppenlandschaften bekannt ist.
Wie sehr würden wir
der Umwelt helfen,
wenn wir alle vegan leben würden?
Für Deutschland gibt es leider
noch keine ausführlichen Studien,
dafür aber für die USA,
die ja auch gute Böden haben.
In den USA entspricht der Ausstoß
aller klimaschädlichen Gase
fast 7 Mio. t CO2 pro Jahr.
Die Landwirtschaft hat daran
einen Anteil von ungefähr 9 %.
Und fast die Hälfte davon
gehen auf das Konto Tierhaltung.
Doch wenn man die gesamte
Tierhaltung abschaffen würde,
würde man dadurch nicht die Hälfte
einsparen, sondern nur ein Drittel.
Das liegt z.B. daran,
dass es dann auch
keine Gülle mehr gäbe zum Düngen.
Man müsste dann
energiereichere Dünger herstellen.
Oder man müsste viele Wiesen
in Ackerfläche umwandeln,
dadurch würde CO2 frei werden, das
vorher in der Wiese gespeichert war.
Aber das nur zur Einordnung.
Denn nach diesen Berechnungen:
1/3 der Emissionen
kann man sparen.
Und man kriegt aus denselben
Ackerflächen mehr Kalorien raus
zur Ernährung der Bevölkerung.
Here's the thing:
Wenn wir aus
dieser komplexen Gleichung
rund um Klimawandel und Ernährung
jetzt nur die Tiere rausnehmen,
sonst gar nichts ändern,
bleiben wir erst mal mit einem
Riesenbatzen Futtergetreide zurück.
Da sind zwar genug Kalorien
für uns alle drin,
aber das ist natürlich
keine ausgewogene Ernährung.
Wir müssten stattdessen
mehr Obst und Gemüse anbauen.
Und die sind im Schnitt
aber anspruchsvoller
und brauchen mehr Ressourcen
als Getreide,
sind damit weniger Klima-freundlich.
Anschaulich wurde das
in dieser amerikanischen Studie,
wo ausgerechnet wurde, was passiert,
wenn alle Amerikaner sich an dich
offiziellen US-Ernährungs-
empfehlungen halten würden.
Zunächst werden in den USA
weniger Kalorien empfohlen,
als gegessen wird.
Wenn diese Kalorienempfehlung
eingehalten werden würde,
damit alle langfristig
normalgewichtig wären,
würde das bereits die
Emissionen um 9 % einsparen.
Dann gibt's natürlich noch
die qualitativen Empfehlungen,
also weniger Burger und Donuts
und mehr Obst und Gemüse
und auch Milchprodukte,
so wird es empfohlen.
Und jetzt kommt ein
sehr interessantes Ergebnis:
Würden sich alle Amerikaner
an die offiziellen
Ernährungsempfehlungen halten,
würden trotz Kalorienreduktion
die Emissionen zunächst steigen,
und zwar nach diesen Berechnungen
um satte 6 %.
Das liegt zum einen an den
vielen empfohlenen Milchprodukten,
für die auch Kühe gehalten
und gefüttert werden müssen.
Aber auch an der starken Zunahme
von Obst und Gemüse.
Wenn wir uns die LCAs
verschiedener Gemüsesorten ansehen,
fällt auf, dass manche Gemüsesorten
viele Emissionen verursachen.
Natürlich nichts
im Vergleich zu Fleisch,
aber im Vergleich
zu Kartoffeln oder Getreide.
Dazu gehören z.B. Avocado,
Auberginen oder Blattsalate.
Auch die Aspekte
Regionalität und Saisonalität
fließen auch
in die Klimabilanz mit ein.
Salatgurken z.B. sind in
der Saison ziemlich klimafreundlich.
Außerhalb der Saison,
wenn sie in beheizten
Gewächshäusern produziert werden,
verzehnfachen sich die Emissionen
und bringen die Gurke auf
dasselbe Klima-Level wie Frischkäse.
Oder Spargel:
lokal im Sommer kein Problem.
Nur frisch aus
Peru oder Mexiko eingeflogen
führt das zu einer
12-13-fachen erhöhten Emission
und macht den Spargel sogar
belastender als Schweinefleisch.
Das Problem verschärft sich
eigentlich nur Jahr um Jahr.
Denn gerade die ökonomisch
aufstrebenden Länder,
deren Fleischkonsum steigt
und wird auch weiter steigen.
Für viele gehört Fleisch
zum erreichten Wohlstand dazu.
Ich denke nicht, dass wir die Leute
davon abbringen können.
Wie bei allen Nachhaltigkeits-Fragen
wird es auch hier nicht diese
eine umsetzbare Superlösung geben.
Stattdessen müssten wir
gleichzeitig möglichst
viele Lösungswege verfolgen.
Z.B. durch Futterforschung.
Dieser Kalorienverlust von der
pflanzlichen Nahrung zum Fleisch
wurde in den
letzten Jahrzehnten immer weniger.
Das liegt u.a.
an überlegteren Futtermischungen,
die effizienter verdaut werden.
Auch die Methanbildung kann durch
geschicktes Futter reduziert werden.
Deswegen wird weltweit an immer
besseren Futtermischungen geforscht.
Und für jeden
von uns persönlich gilt:
Nur wenn ich es nicht schaffe,
vegan zu leben oder vegetarisch,
muss das ja nicht heißen:
Gut, dann halt nicht.
Z.B. fand eine britische Studie
heraus, dass gemäßigte Fleischesser,
die weniger als 50 g Fleisch
pro Tag aßen,
im Gegensatz
zu starken Fleischessern,
die über 100 g Fleisch pro Tag aßen,
900 kg CO2-Emissionen
pro Jahr sparten.
Das entspricht immerhin einem
Hin- und Rückflug nach New York.
Auf eine ähnliche Größenordnung
kamen schwedische Wissenschaftler,
die ausrechneten,
was passieren würde,
wenn alle Menschen im
Land die Hälfte des Fleisches
aus ihrem Essen ersetzen würden
durch proteinreiche Hülsenfrüchte
wie Bohnen, Erbsen und so.
Außerdem,
wenn wir schon Tiere essen,
können wir das
auch effizienter machen,
indem wir möglichst viel
von dem Tier verwerten
und nicht nur Hähnchenbrust
oder Rinderfilet essen.
Und generell weniger verschwenden.
Wenn wir mehr Essen kaufen,
als wir essen,
ist das
direkte Ressourcenverschwendung.
Unabhängig vom Fleisch
kann man auch versuchen,
sich möglichst regional
und saisonal zu ernähren,
was natürlich auch
einen Verzicht bedeutet.
z.B. auf die Avocado aus Mexiko
oder Beeren im Winter.
Also wenn es
um Ernährung und Klima geht,
läuft jeder positive Beitrag auf
irgendeine Art von Verzicht hinaus.
Die Frage ist: Auf was könnt
ihr am ehesten verzichten?
Was könnt ihr am besten beitragen?
Wenn ihr euch vegan, regional
und saisonal ernährt: super.
Und wenn ihr euren Fleischkonsum
um die Hälfte reduziert.
Hauptsache, ihr tut, was ihr könnt.
Wenn ihr dafür Inspiration braucht
und wenn euch noch andere Aspekte
des Klimawandels interessieren,
müsst ihr bei meinem Kollegen Frank
von Die Frage vorbeischauen.
Ich bin der einzige Idiot, der bei
dem Wetter mit dem Fahrrad fährt.
1, 2, 3. Ey!
Und hinterlasst ihm mal
ein paar Keks-Emojis.
Die haben momentan
und die nächsten Wochen eine ganze
Serie zum Klimawandel. Deswegen:
Hallo, Freunde der Sonne,
ich bin Frank von Die Frage.
Auf meinem Kanal
gehe ich aktuell der Frage nach:
Was kann ich
gegen den Klimawandel tun?
Wenn ihr das sehen wollt,
klickt doch mal da. - Sehr gut!